education in in america has been
disrupted significantly
our system wasn't working for many
learners pre-covered
and now we have an opportunity to
reimagine
what that looks like moving forward
my name is joanna smith i'm the ceo of
all here
and we help schools to curb chronic
absenteeism
using chat bots powered by ai all here
is my first company my first
business i was teaching and kind of had
stumbled onto this problem and got into
entrepreneurship
as a means to scale what was working for
me
students were missing anywhere from
increments of like one to three days
and it has a snowball effect
when a student is missing school what
we're seeing now
is in terms of attendance it's not just
are you physically present right it's
not just are you here or not is are you
learning during the school day
and it's culminated in a redefinition
of what it means to go to school in
america
[Music]
am i living my american dream i would
say
yes and i would say personally
the fact that i am a mother i am a ceo
of a company and i am both of those
things at the same time
that to me is my dream is that i could
do both of those things well
when i say yes and as the mother of a
ten-month-old daughter
seeing the way the world is right now i
worry
that the inequities in society
are ones that would unduly
impact her ability to achieve her dreams
so when you ask me to me what does the
american
dream mean is that every single person
regardless of their race their
background their gender
has the opportunity to go after that
which motivates them which excites them
and which fulfills them we have a long
way to go to ensure that
everybody has the opportunity to live
their dream
whatever that is for them
you